ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage Chris Robertson cloudbuilt in
Pierre in that I say that right Wow
yeah I'm your host Chris waters the
Chris is on stage to talk about star
citizen of course like the the big story
of this game
phenomenal crowdfunding success and now
parts of it are playable parts of it are
coming out people are getting their
hands on yeah so people can do more than
just walk around a hangar and see that
[ __ ] you can fly you can fly some of
them not all the ships yet but we're
working busily to get all of them sort
of see a flight ready and yes so it's
the first very first early taste of
space combat but it's actually only in
the single seater ship so not the big we
got bigger ships that you can you and
your friends can fly and so that will be
arena commander V 2.0 and we're actually
only on V zero point eight so the 1.0
arena commander is the single-seat ships
everybody being able to play
head-to-head and all the game modes so
right now we launched before that
because we wanted to get in people's
hands people were pretty impatient to
play let you put it that way yeah and so
right now you can play against the AI in
sort of a swarm mode or a Ford motor
however you want to call it and this
week we're starting our multiplayer
testing but we have to open up because
the problem we have with what we're
doing is that even though we're in super
early stage like pre alpha we've got so
many backers like it's like a full
launch I mean I think there was over
250,000 people eligible just to play the
alpha dog fighting yeah when you put
something out there it's not just like a
small crew of people on forums checking
this out it's hundreds of thousands you
know it's hundreds so then you've got to
have a robust launch you've got that
many people playing it so the
single-player is easier the multiplayer
requires a lot of servers that will spin
up yeah so we've got a whole sort of
dynamic system where the more people
come online the more servers spin up in
the cloud but we're just sort of going
easy with that at the beginning so this
week you know it's in the hundreds next
week will be in the thousands and then
eventually when we're pretty confident
the system's stable then everyone get to
it and that's sort of when we call it
1.0 so
all right we're still early stages still
early going but we're gonna take a look
at it here what sort of where we gonna
go in this demo what are we gonna check
out well so I'm just going to sort of
show a little bit of the experience of
the arena commander we start in the
hangar and then the idea where the arena
commander is and I sort of like to do
everything in fiction I mean you know
there's these yeah I know
we just did a freelancer commercial this
past weekend but I like to instead of
sort of doing stuff that could be
constrained as like talking directly
about the game like sort of an in
fiction so we like to show off the ships
as a commercial that was done 900 years
in the future in our universe oh and the
same again with the arena commander the
concept really is this is a simulation
inside the universe there like as a
pilot you know so in our universe you
know you go between planets and there's
you know obviously you can get attacked
by pirates so there's lots of danger out
there and and if you invested like time
and effort and building of your ship you
don't want to lose it so a real Amanda
is sort of a simulation that will allow
people to get online in the universe and
test out their flight skills without
risking losing their ship like that
combat muscles sort of you know you lay
around a little bit but not put it on
the line yeah learn learn how to learn
how to use your ship and also along the
term we're gonna sort of make it sort of
a in fiction eSports in the universe so
when the actual full persistent universe
is out there the arena commander itself
will have competitions and all the
players can join and got leagues and
you've got yes we can even in a bar in
like one of the planets you could go and
they can be broadcasting the arena
commander you know final and stuff like
that so we're really going to try and do
that there's also a later version of it
which will also just be racing we have
this fictional thing we call Marie Cup
racing inside the universe and having a
lot of our fiction and so you know not
everybody wants to just fight some
people want to write and so we really
try to make it sort of in fiction and so
the idea is the hangar which is what we
we sort of released last year which
would allow you to walk around lucky
your ship so I'm sort of in the hangar
right now looking quite eight the hangar
you know yeah so I'll put on like to put
on a helmet because we need to wear a
helmet for flying people like the
elements in any first men yeah exactly
but interesting to note the helmet does
not meet come with a HUD I don't know it
does once you get into the ship oh yeah
yeah once it's boots fires up and
there's something to see yeah I guess so
but you know if I just go that's my
character right here but I'll just walk
over to so this is a hangar this is
actually a deluxe hangar I think we just
set up for this demo there's three
different ships you can fly an arena
commander at the beginning one is the
Hornet which is sort of the custom
dogfighting [ __ ] which is the one I'm
walking up to right now and then in the
background over here I just show that's
the 300 I which is sort of more our sort
of BMW sort of a little more sleek
sleeker and then the base the starter
ship which is Aurora which is kind of
over here that tiny little thing over
there yeah yeah but we'll get in the
Hornet because it's a sort of one with
the most firepower in the sexiest all
right well yeah I mean and scale is such
a big part of star citizen and such a
huge part of its appeal you know you're
you're starting off with a one-seater
yeah and you move up and everything's
now it's essentially everything's run
inside a first person engine I mean
we're inside CryEngine we've done a lot
of modification to it but it said the
fidelity of you know a next-gen
first-person game but you can get in the
vehicles and fly and get in the bigger
vehicles and you go from planet to
planet so there's the level of ambitions
pretty crazy so you know so what happens
is when you get into a ship this sort of
dogfight eligible you know I can look
around it but I'll just I'll go here and
we'll go into the sort of the single
player mode drone sim and we'll launch
and go into broker moon now in the in
the final game there won't be a loading
screen like this because this they'll be
streaming text so essentially if you fly
into something you'll you're basically
getting your ship and will fly out and
you'll sort of have a transition and
we'll sort of seamlessly stream in and
the other areas bay doors will open
yeah I'll girl yeah so I mean we handle
that with sort of cinematic transitions
but it's all sort of live so you can
sort of be in like the equivalent to be
you be inside your say like the
Millennium Falcon would be an exam
another we have Mela but the Millennium
Falcon ship you could be like walking
around inside it as it's taking off you
can see stuff around you and then you
fly any transition through the clouds
and then you sort of be in space and so
that will that's going to be cool that's
sort of a tech that's in process it's so
for the arena commander we're just sort
of we're now loading into this space
level I've got a bit of a custom level
here in arena ground because I sort of
wanted to sort of show the fidelity of
the ship before getting attacked by a
bunch of vandal so this is a Hornet out
in space and so like one of the things
so like actually if I just sort of let
me just zoom in here we can sort of see
the ice absolutely not so close but
everything's done in what's called PBR
which is a rendering technique that
makes everything sort of feel like my
current camera down and let's go a light
will shine on me
you're looking very stoic
yeah I believe airy Stewart but like you
know if I look around you can see me of
my helmet so the fidelity that we're
doing and this is sort of like I mean
even the ship here is three hundred
thousand four hundred thousand Polly's
and the character themselves close to a
hundred thousand and then one of the
things that it's pretty interesting and
it's kind of a little bit it's a
learning curve for people who are
starting to play it is that we've
decided because we have such a big game
and you can fly ships from all sides
small ones all the way up to these
really huge ships yeah that we've
decided to do a very different flight
model than most space games I've ever
done including the ones I've made and
different than Wing Commander differ in
the privateer
so instead of doing what's essentially a
simplified atmospheric model which is
what most space games do and that's much
more like a plane so you know you pull
back on the stick now like in atmosphere
it's like you instantly get sort of
direct one-on-one relation between your
stick and movement because you're
cutting through the atmosphere there's a
there's a force we're in space you have
no resistance so what we've actually
done is we 100% model everything
correctly it's so this ship itself and
all the items are attached to it they
change the center of mass and then what
we and where all the thrusters are it's
actually applying force in the physics
engine at that point at a linear side at
the thrust that's been determined by the
intelligent flight system and so what
happens is as you fly around it's got a
slightly different contract it's got a
little more as sort of inertia like I
guess if I go in the let's see if I just
go to the front you sort of I let go it
sort of moves a little bit because it's
got a little bit of that
of asteroids field because really all
those thrusters are countering thrust
and they don't deploy immediately and so
it takes a little bit of getting used to
but what it doesn't that allow is a huge
amount of extra skill and other options
but you basically have to sort of
anticipate your stopping distance right
because it's like in a car if you come
up to a stop sign of 50 miles now you
don't hit the brake right of the line
you start to do it before and so you
kind of have to do that with what we're
doing and I've got to hold the thruster
force the weight of the ship and I'll
tackle and the calculating right there
and the key with it is that that means
that you know in the old way of doing
games what would normally happen would
be I'm going to turn off my safeties
what normally would happen is that you
would basically say okay the ship rolls
at this rate pitches at this rate yards
at this rate it can accelerate so fast
and has a top speed so to make a
difference in the feel of a ship you
basically can just change those
parameters yeah which just means every
you know bigger ships turn slower or
accelerate slower but they all kind of
handle the same whereas in this system
because everything uses correct physics
and the center of it like if I'm going
around you can sort of see me sliding
around on these things
uh-huh what's the delight of the fans
who are on yeah so but the thing that
happens in in that particular case is
that if you just had a smaller compact
ship and a bigger ship with exactly the
same engines they would handle
differently so it's much like cars you
know you can have a car that has the
same horsepower engine but depending on
whether the engines at the front or the
back or how it's set up it will actually
control significantly so it was actually
a big design decision because we just
sort of felt like we had so many
different ships and we also wanted a lot
of different things you can customize
like what your loadout is and and you
know what thrusters or engines you put
on it so we needed to have a system that
would simulate that and it would feel
sort of holistic so that's kind of the
big thing it's still early stages
because the ifcs system itself we're
still tweaking because essentially it's
so complicated that you have to have
basically a fly-by-wire can computer
that sort of take your input and and and
essentially about you know on the
outside change it to what the thrusters
are doing to some
for the pilots actions sure and so you
know there's a little bit of finessing
that and also making it work well for
the marriage and the joy so that's the
whole point of like doing the sort of
the early test and the arena commander
getting out there to the backers is to
really get ones feedback and then also a
little bit to sort of educate people on
a different way of doing so we're doing
it very different so I'm going to bring
in some enemy right now so they can
attack me but it does definitely enable
you to do different kinds of things so
if I pull out here like I canti couple
and and now I'm like actually going
backwards like in physics and I can go
back into the control method it'll take
the thing so let me just find the
enemies it seems like the upshot of the
the whole sort of system is to make you
know make that inertia so important and
make that make that ship identity and
that under sense so yeah it's a lot more
yeah I mean I like to say that this is
going to be a lot more they'll feel a
little more like asteroids then it will
like like even a Wing Commander in the
past but I think we can do some stuff
that's really makes that kind of fun
all right well we I'm gonna take a
question or two over Twitter we had one
earlier from Kenneth Ellis wondering you
mentioned before that the arena
commander gives you that great
opportunity to get your ship blown up
respawn all that he's a little worried
about ship insurance and how is that
gonna work you know once he actually
takes it out maybe encounter some
pirates in actual space and it runs
afoul of them that's one of you guys
have sort of mapped out at this point or
I know it's easy to talk about during
dogfighting
but no no so essentially all ships come
with insurance we add this thing for the
early baptism we had lifetime insurance
which essentially meant that you'd never
have to re-up your insurance but every
basic ship in the game comes with a
certain amount of insurance like I'm you
know two months or three months of
insurance and then in the game credits
when your insurance policies up you just
got to spend a bit more credit so
essentially as long as you're running
around doing missions making money in
the game yeah you'll make money you'll
be able to afford the deductible and you
know it's a hundred percent like the
real world right and we have other
things I mean you know as a mother
California Chris yeah they definitely
are especially since I didn't tell them
to come just yet
surprise so to clarify are these actual
pilots coming up here is this a I know
this is a yeah yeah so I mean I guess
you did summon them with the press of a
keys yeah yeah and I brought him in
though because the you know the
multiplayer mode is like I think I said
getting rolled out this week so we have
it multiplied we've been playing
internally multiplayer but elsewhere if
you had some guys back it's now taking a
[ __ ]
so in terms of I guess in terms of that
moat maneuverability you know what boy
what kind of pilot sensation do you want
a cult say with that you know you mean
obviously you want the pilot to feel in
control of their vehicle yeah but you
also want them to feel like I let myself
get shot you know like there are they
are out in space and they they do have
these forces to contend with and that
you know they're engineering that
creates the shipping creates this thrust
in this inertia is a certain way how do
you sort of find the sweet spot between
like trying to make it realistic and
also trying to make it something that
the pilots gonna enjoy pick up so that's
kind of what we're dealing with now
that's kind of one of the reasons why we
released the V zero point eight is we
kind of wanted to get it out to a wider
feedback group to try and hit that sweet
spot because I really keen to have a
system that is that sort of flexible and
gives that many characteristics is when
I have so many ships but obviously part
of the issue is you know it's got to be
easy at the beginning right you see and
you start to play it's gotta be kind of
fun so kind of like my goal just showing
off the damage modeling right now right
part of my goal is to sort of make it at
the very beginning sort of fun and easy
to play almost like sort of a starcraft
where you can just use a mouse right but
then if you get good at it you know all
the like shortcuts and all the extra
things you're going to do because that's
and that's sort of the idea having a
systems-based approach allows a lot more
dials to tweak and turn and on facial
articulation and our ship itself the
actual ship itself is actually fairly
dumb what it has is about 50 or 60 items
plugged into it so the thrusters are all
items the weapons are all items the
radar is an item the weapons controls an
item the power plants an item so the
shield is Larry's are going to be able
to consume and they can do they can
choose and customize and then also
they're all connected so like the power
point power plant provides power and
then a lot of the different systems
require power if the power plan goes
down and gets relegated then they'll be
less power of the systems and they won't
work as well I just won't work so like
the lights on the the lights on the ship
will turn off if you lose your power and
stuff like that so
it's all these things happen if you lose
a wing for instance you lose some
thrusters that will change how your ship
will fly because the moment inertia
changes and the power so because we've
gone to a lot of effort to build this
systems in and we were allowing players
to also change the power distribution
between the different items and so a lot
of that will come online in the next
month the system's actually in there and
in debug mode so we can do it all but we
still like tweaking the hard to get all
that to work and so it's kind of one of
these things where it's a pretty
complicated system we want to get out
they want to get feedback we want to see
where people have trouble and then okay
well let's simplify this and make a sort
of simple easy thing to do in front or
and then the experts where they really
get into it and they really want to do
some kind of fun tricky maneuvers they
they essentially think they can and so
that's kind of the nice thing about the
crowdfunding set up is that you you
basically have this huge focus group I
mean you've got this large group of
people they're really passionate about
the game
yeah they got a lot of opinions and
you're not just getting data back from
them from what you guys have built into
the game their sound and all no no this
thing and you know so it's like if I was
doing this the traditional method you
would hire a focus group and there'll be
20 or 30 people yeah but that's a small
sample you know we've got hundreds of
thousands of people playing it that are
actually right there giving us feedback
of like I like this or I don't like that
it's interesting to see people discover
things so like on the flight model at
the beginning there was some fair number
of people that were like oh you know I
don't like this this doesn't feel like
what I'm used to and then out of time
there was people going oh you know the
the physics the simulation is so good
that the flight model appears bad and
they're like you don't do this and this
and this and like they were discovering
the different modes and like oh my god I
can do these extra maneuvers and do all
this sort of stuff so it's all that kind
of stuff that's really great to get
early on because that will just allow us
to hone it over the next year year and a
half before the full games out and
hopefully by then we'll have something
that'll be really fun to me it's already
fun to fly around and play and this is
we're super early I mean I this is this
early in the process I would never have
a game this polished so and making it a
public release sort of forces you to
have it failing to bring it up to that
level yeah so it's just a great process
and I'm sort of really enjoying it even
getting my back half of my ship
completely shut off it well clearly you
are clearly enjoying it and clearly you
know this the scope of this game is is
something that I think has really drawn
people to it but thank you for coming on
and sort of drilling down into this you
know very specific but also very
integral part of the other small citizen
experience no it's cool and I actually
really you know anyone out there there's
a backer I mean it's no please play it
give us your feedback if you want to
check it out you know you should come
check it out as well it's I mean it's
it's a really great process I'm really
enjoying making a game this way where
you're sort of involving a much larger
group of people yeah but for me it's
better than involving someone that's for
marketing because these are people that
love playing the game and so it's like
okay you know so at that point I can't
get mad at anyone even if they're saying
I don't like the way this works because
yeah they're fans of the show yeah
they're invested as well yeah absolutely
Chris thank you so much are you open on
star citizen it's looking great and more
to come from that a like imminently
arena commander mode coming out this
week available for backers I can check
it out star citizen comm Roberts space
industries comm Roberts space industries
calm like you're saying all in fiction
right exactly 100% that's that's the
hella go excellent all right folks we'll
be back shortly with a demo of entwined
game that announced during Sony press
conference we're gonna see some birds
fishes and it's gonna be wonderful